about Darvin ham as you see the two
stars getting some rest right now a rare
rare thing we're talking about the job
he did two and ten start you are in a
market where the scrutiny and
expectations are always high I don't
care what your roster says you are
coaching the Superstar one of the
greatest to ever do it and arguably the
highest IQ player in LeBron James who
does not suffer fools and you've got to
command his respect uh you've got
Anthony Davis who has you know battled
injuries and availability at times a lot
was put on the play that the first year
head coach and my man stepped up and met
every single one of them marks a lot of
moving parts and basically coaching
different roster after the trade
deadline and handling a lot of those
tactics and the accompanying Dynamics
with
[Applause]
edel skill